in the late 19th century the picturesque
town of Aurora Texas nestled among the
Serene Texan Plains was a tight-knit
community
focused on Farming and ranching
however on April 17 1897 a remarkable
event unfolded that would forever alter
the town's history
the Aurora UFO incident a captivating
encounter but being the townspeople and
a mysterious aircraft captured the
nation's attention and left an enduring
Legacy of speculation and wonder
back in 1897
the concept of extraterrestrial life
sparked both skepticism and fascination
with a population of only 300 residents
Aurora stood far removed from the
bustling cities cultivating a simple and
peaceful existence
yet on that fateful day the Tranquility
of Aurora would be shattered by an
inexplicable phenomenon
according to historical accounts an
unusual Airship described as
cigar-shaped and made of an unknown
metal crashed into the windmill owned by
judge j s Proctor
[Music]
the impact resulted in significant
damage to the windmill structure and
Scattered debris across the property
including fragments of the peculiar
craft
Witnesses marveled at the wreckage
noting the presence of hieroglyphic-like
markings on the ship's exterior
some eyewitnesses claim that the pilot
of the crashed Airship was seen
attempting to repair the damaged craft
before succumbing to their injuries
[Music]
this detail adds to the Intrigue
surrounding the incident as it suggests
that the pilot was not simply a passive
passenger but actively involved in the
events
among those who gathered at the crash
site was S E Hayden a local newspaper
reporter
with meticulous detail Hayden chronicled
the events surrounding the Aurora UFO
incident
eyewitnesses shared their extraordinary
accounts claiming that the pilot of the
Airship was not of this world
descriptions varied with some witnesses
mentioning a small statured being While
others described a humanoid figure
according to their testimonies the
otherworldly pilot perished in the crash
and its remains were allegedly buried in
the Aurora Cemetery
The Sensational claims surrounding the
incident turned Aurora into a focal
point for UFO enthusiasts historians and
Skeptics alike
news of the Aurora UFO incident spread
rapidly capturing the attention of
newspapers across the country
the story gained National Intrigue and
fervor sparking debates and curiosity
in the aftermath of the incident a
public meeting was convened in Aurora to
discuss the peculiar occurrence
the townspeople gathered to debate the
veracity of the claims
Skeptics put forth theories suggesting a
possible meteorite impact or a failed
experimental aircraft
however others fervently believed in the
presence of extraterrestrial life
considering the crash as undeniable
proof of its existence
As Time passed the incident gradually
faded Into Obscurity becoming a
forgotten fragment of History
yet decades later researchers in UFO
enthusiasts sought to delve deeper into
the Aurora UFO incident
they endeavored to locate the alleged
grave of the Extraterrestrial pilot in
the Aurora Cemetery
to their disappointment they discovered
that the grave had been Disturbed and
The Headstone mysteriously vanished
leaving behind unanswered questions and
intensifying the Intrigue surrounding
the incident
despite the passage of time the Aurora
UFO incident continues to capture the
imagination of Aurora's residents and
visitors
it has become an integral part of the
town's identity
attracting tourists and UFO enthusiasts
from around the world
the incident stands as a testament to
the enduring Allure of the unknown and
the Perpetual question of whether we are
truly alone in the vastness of the
universe
[Music]
foreign